well good evening from London welcome to
Pearson organizer many of the
stereotypes about Millennials almost as
lazy as some of them are they like
avocados on toast they take photos of
avocados on toast bad tattoos skinny
jeans dating apps cats you get the
picture and sensorship of course like a
lot of stereotypes they begin life with
a kernel of Truth a major survey in the
U.S found that a plurality of people
aged 25 to 34 now I think using the
wrong pronouns should be a criminal
offense almost half of them think you
should be prosecuted for saying he
instead of she in fact he is becoming a
she or if he or she just wants to be
they or thinks they should be a she he
they or something like a cat you could
be forgiven for being as confused about
this as some of them are and that's the
point most decent people have no real
problem with referring to trans people
by their chosen gender I try and do it
myself everything else is just polite
and good manners but most decent people
also find all this completely baffling
stop someone in the streets of Barnsley
or Baltimore and ask them for their
personal preferred pronouns they'll ask
you what the hell you're talking about
look what happened when CNN the very
Paragons of virtue signaling analyze the
disastrous impact that trans influencer
Dylan Mulvaney who until last year
identified as a gay man uh had on sales
a Bud Light
they don't like the way Delvin Mulvaney
was treated after this whole controversy
started he courses the transgender uh
person they were going to uh sponsor and
go along with with Bud Light they didn't
like how Bud Light didn't stand by him
oh dear
but he wasn't him last year but not
anymore and the next day CNN where I
used to work for the fine people all
very well intentioned had to issue a
groveling apology
before we wrap up today we do want to
make an important note yesterday in a
segment about transgender influencer
Dylan Mulvaney who was featured in Bud
light's recent campaign she was
mistakenly referred to by the wrong
pronoun and CNN aims to honor
individuals ways of identifying
themselves and we apologize for that
error
I mean really
execution is too good for that but you
see that's how difficult it all is isn't
it should CNN journalist now be jailed
for that obvious hate crime
and criminal offense or not the tyranny
of the pronoun police is all around us
misgendering can get you kicked off
YouTube which for some people has
removed there's some main source of
income it briefly led to the what is a
woman documentary by Matt Walsh being
banned on Twitter and Oxford College
just warned it will expel students for
misgendering each other the UK
government's long-winded guidance for
schools on trans-pupils has today been
delayed reportedly because of legal
wrangling over whether teachers must use
a student's preferred pronouns many
businesses now require their staff to
wear pronoun badges or sign off their
emails with their pronouns and if you
accept all of that criminalization
probably looks like they're logical Next
Step yeah sling the miscreants in prison
now in my view what should actually be
illegal if you're going to get into
gender criminality might be the idea of
biological men destroying women born
with biological female bodies in women's
sport that's a bit of a crime to me or
biological men demanding access to
female changing rooms full of biological
females many of them grow young
or biological male rapists who identify
as women at their trials to get into
women's prisons
maybe that should be a crime and if you
think that makes me a transphobe I'd say
you're the one with the phobia of Common
Sense